Bienvenido a France 24 qué significancia
estratégica tienen los misiles Patriot
para Ucrania y cuánto tardarán en hacer
los operativos cambiarán de alguna
manera el balance del conflicto
Bueno vamos a verla primero que nada
Gracias por la oportunidad de estar aquí
con ustedes
el tema de vamos a empezar por la más
fácil que es cuánto tiempo se demora en
que se puedan utilizar el problema es
que es un sistema muy pero Ultra
sofisticado y que para los que van a
operar los ucranios que lo van a operar
van a requerir como mínimo varios meses
y yo creo que lo más antes posible que
pudiera utilizarse sería ya para la
primavera del 2023 Así que Empezando por
ahí y eso es como un poco eso es muy
optimista yo creo que hasta más tiempo
en realidad para para ser totalmente
efectivo el tema Mira el tema de estas
baterías es que son súper efectivas son
muy precisas pero nada más que pueden
disparar a un misil un avión o cualquier
amenaza aérea a una instancia de entre
20 millas a 100 millas y Ucrania tiene
una distancia de este a oeste unos ocho
y de Norte del sur 500 Así que en
realidad es una batería solamente de
patriart va a ser muy difícil en que
pueda vamos a ir defender en en gran
parte lugares en Ucrania yo creo que
posiblemente una ciudad o un algún lugar
en particular Así que al fin lo que
quiero decir es que yo creo que esto es
como un poco más simbólico
que este práctico sí quería preguntarle
por otra razón importante que hemos
visto hoy Y es que Estados Unidos no
habla explícitamente de la defensa
territorial ucraniana como pide
volodímir zelensky Por qué cree que
puede ser puede tener la reacción de
Rusia
bueno Esta es una guerra muy particular
no porque es como que queremos defender
a Ucrania pero al mismo tiempo No
queremos amenazar a Rusia a la misma vez
y eso es un balance muy delicado
mantener pero es lo que estamos
intentando es lo que está intentando no
solamente Estados Unidos pero tan y por
eso es que otan y Estados Unidos no se
quieren comprometer a la parte del de
recuperar de todo el territorio
ucraniano que los rusos se llevaron
empezando en el 2014 porque eso puede
ser que demore una algún tipo de César
de fuego o un acuerdo de paz y muy
brevemente cuál cree que puede ser la
reacción de Rusia entre estos nuevos
anuncios hechos hoy
bueno en particular vamos a ir como dije
de los misiles de Patriot No creo que se
al fin del día Ellos saben que esto es
más simbólico que que no y así que no
creo que se van a molestar por eso y
pero también estamos proveyendo unos
como usted dice
ochocientos cincuenta millones de
dólares en municiones que sí pueden
utilizar para los sistemas que ellos ya
tienen pero lo importante aquí es que es
todo la mayoría que está todo pero la
mayoría de estas municiones
son se van a utilizar de una forma
defensiva Y eso Entonces le da un poco
más tranquilidad Pero podemos decir para
los Estados Unidos que no los van a
utilizar de una forma ofensiva en el
territorio de Rusia por los ucranianos